in 2001 I worked at Microsoft and I
worked on a product called the Encarta
encyclopedia for those of you for those
of you who don't know what an
encyclopedia is it's it's a bunch of
books and here's the Encyclopedia
Britannica this is what I had when I was
a kid and the Encyclopedia Britannica
from the 1700s until the 1990s was kind
of a state of the art of information now
all the information in the world is in
these books they could just look through
find whatever you need flipped through
and then Microsoft came out with the
Encarta encyclopedia here's Steve
Ballmer CEO of Microsoft at the time
talking about this encyclopedia it's
amazing what was so amazing was that the
Encarta encyclopedia was on not a bunch
of books but a cd-rom and for those of
you who don't remember what a cd-rom is
it's like a little silver frisbee with
data stored on it you could put it in
your computer anyway there were about
six of them to have the Encyclopedia
arguably not as convenient as books but
it was pretty cool and I worked on the
Encarta encyclopedia there were great
articles photos videos 3d tours all
kinds of awesome stuff in the
encyclopedia 2001
we're just dominating the digital
encyclopedia market which I mean II feel
something something and this product
came out that's you know kind of kind of
cute and kind of a cute little thing
they got there we talked about it around
the office this is an interesting idea
anybody can write an encyclopedia
article it's free it's right online huh
it's kind of a novelty pretty
interesting time passes we're still
feeling pretty good about ourselves 2003
Wikipedia starts looking a little bit
more sophisticated and at this point
it's got more articles in it than the
Encarta encyclopedia and there's another
problem because people are going online
increasingly they're running a search
when they want information and as you
know you run a search on Google you get
a Wikipedia article and the contents not
always great but it's always there it's
always free so you can imagine we were
alarmed by this we knew this was gonna
affect our market share and we had to
figure out something to do so we did
what you do in these situations we had
meetings we brainstormed
you know when often my sort of desk and
came up with ideas and tried to pitch
them and argue for my my way of thinking
and I actually was able to convince the
team that we should do my idea which was
to I'm a designer to redesign the
encyclopedia to really showcase how good
our content was how much better it was
than what you could get for free on
Wikipedia so I convinced them I
convinced them to do my idea and we
built it and it took a while you know we
had to design it spec it out build it
test it all those things in the end
here's the encyclopedia you have to
remember this is a long time ago but
this was very futuristic it's
three-dimensional spinning around
grabbing information opening it up you
know and and we were we were pretty
excited about this
so engineering team we finished this and
we send it off to be manufactured
printed on compact discs and and so
we're feeling good but we did have to
sell it at this point we still had to
sell what we could create it and in
those days you may not remember but
there was no app store if you wanted to
buy an app you had to go to a store and
so the software was in boxes on the
store and you would you know you'd look
at all the boxes and you'd say oh this
is interesting and you turn it over and
look look at the specs of wall I wonder
if I want to take that home and you'd
have to decide if it was worth your
while so if it was then you know great
and the box was important so you you'd
think that what we would have put on the
box would be well the name of the
product would make sense a big picture
of it so you'd know all of our hard work
you could see what we'd done and some
compelling description of it would also
be nice something that made it sound
great but but that's not what we did we
did a slight error in planning where we
did all this and then kind of right at
the last minute brought in the marketing
team and we said hey look at what we
built isn't this fantastic and don't you
think people were gonna want just to
talk about this on the box and they were
like oh no if that's what people are
gonna want to pay for we do have these
few discovery videos that we've added
and I think good week so anyway they
hired an outside agency to build the box
so another sort of layer of
communication this was the box
as a big picture of president george w
bush on the france big discovery channel
logo remember when we thought president
bush was bad and then if you look really
closely if you look really closely you
might notice if you have really good
vision that it says here
high five point five new visual browser
which i don't even know what that means
anyway so you can tell I'm a little I'm
a little a little bitter about this but
so I probably don't have to tell you
what happened in this story and in fact
if you a card has gone today and if you
go online if you go to Google and you
search for Encarta the first results
it says it says Microsoft Encarta was
was just one oh man so many years of my
life but but I do wonder I do wonder if
I could go back in time if I really did
have a time machine what could have
changed and how it could have changed
the course of events with the Encarta
encyclopedia and one thing that seems
pretty obvious is it might have been a
good idea to talk to those folks well
sooner maybe we could have convinced
them maybe they could have convinced us
that probably would have been good one
thing that's clear is we were not
thinking about the moment in the store
we were thinking about the heart of the
problem the engineering the design the
product once you had it on your computer
we were thinking about making that as
great as possible but this other key
moment was actually in the store that
was like the elbow the product was the
hand and we should have been thinking
about the elbow and the other thing we
didn't think about you know there's all
these other ideas we didn't try out we
thought some were too risky one of those
ideas was to give the articles away for
free online to make them free
competitors online peers of the
wikipedia articles and they were better
the articles were professionally written
in they had photos videos that we had
paid for they were really excellent so
would that have made a difference when
people ran a search I don't know I don't
know if it would have made a difference
in the long run but maybe it would have
helped Microsoft at any rate that was
actually the elbow of the problem and we
should have been watching the elbow the
whole time
instead we were too focused on the hand
well we'll move on from that little sad
story the year 2007 I left Microsoft I
went to go work at Google because I'm a
traitor and I I was really at this point
really interested in how products are
developed and how people spend their
time organize their time and I was
really excited to find out how did they
do it at Google Google had this
reputation for being for a large company
very fast and nimble and I really wanted
to find out how they went from an idea
to launching and so I got inside and it
turned out that it was pretty much
pretty much the exact same thing
actually the engineers would have this
idea they would build it build it build
it and then they would oh could you
explain at the last second to the
marketers could jukes we have this
Google Wave do you think that people
like marketers are like Oh God Oh
why did you yeah so anyway this is what
happened but there was another kind of
project there where people the engineers
would have an idea and it would just
never launch I'm just never launched
they've just kind of tinker on it 20%
time kind of tinkering and actually I
participated in one of these projects we
had an idea in 2007 for this thing that
we called Google meeting we thought it'd
be really cool if you could have a
multi-user video conference right in it
right in the web browser and you know at
that time you usually give a Skype if I
could download an app but we thought
right in the browser you could have
multiple video channels and we thought
we had like all the back in tech to make
it work and so me and a couple of you
know an engineer and a PM we kind of
just tinker on this tinkerer on this and
we did this in 2007-2008 and finally in
2009 we got together for a week and he
said you know I've visited them they
worked in Stockholm and I went to
Stockholm in January for for a week I
don't know if any of you have been in
Stockholm in January but I hope well if
you haven't I have a photo of it here
it's a joke it's a black folk is it's
really dark it's really dark and cold
it's fairly miserable outside so you
really would you know it's a great time
to focus it's a great time to focus so
so so we all cleared all the calendar of
everything and we got in a room and we
just said we're gonna focus on this
thing together so so we said like how
should this thing look how should it
work let's try to make a prototype in
one week and we did we kind of mocked up
this sort of rough idea of how it should
work and if you look carefully you can
see me without a beard and then we
actually the engineer built a prototype
of that very simple thing and it's very
you know crude and simple these are just
thumbnails down at the bottom not video
feeds but it was the fundamental idea
worked in the the prototype we actually
were able to share with our teammates
and we started having video calls using
this thing and then we started sharing
it around the company and pretty soon
all of Google was using this thing
because it had it was real it wasn't
just us talking on the whiteboard it's
pretty cool eventually this thing in
2011 launched as Google Hangouts and and
actually just this year in 2017 it
launched us what we intended which was
software for meetings
so in a way that actually took ten years
but but what I thought was really cool
about it was that we went from this kind
of thing to to this somehow we had we
had gotten like all of the the work that
we needed to do we had focused in a much
a different way and we had gotten to the
heart of the problem much much faster
effectively I looked back on that I
thought you know that elbow of that kind
of the key moment was was that week and
I started to wonder about this idea of
design I'm a designer I had historically
been designing products I'd worked on
Gmail and Google Talk and and then
hangouts while I was at Google but I
started thinking about how I might
design time differently and if there is
a way to structure time so that you
recreated a moment like we had in
Stockholm so if you remember back I want
you to think back to when you started
your current job and hopefully when you
started your job you were excited about
it and you know if you're a founder
maybe you founded the company and I hope
you were excited about it but if you
hate your job just imagine but so you
imagine this moment you know like really
excited about it it's the first day of
work you come in you've got a new email
address no messages in your inbox you've
got a new you know your calendar is
totally free and you've got this you're
excited and you're like all right let's
do this I'm great and you start to meet
your new smart insightful funny charming
vaguely attractive teammates and you're
like all right and you start having like
one-on-one meetings with them and you
start being invited to projects and
you're like all right we are cooking we
are doing this thing and like you've got
stuff going on you're like I'm in the
flow and then you know pretty soon some
more stuff on your calendar and then
like after a while you've got a lot of
stuff on the calendar and then you're
like you gotta like color code it to
kind of keep track what's going on and
there pretty soon you're just like oh
god oh my god and it's just like it just
feels like like this like you're just
like trying to like
like he's trying to survive and I can't
cross the street and so
so it's a lot of times this is how it
works eels like you just need know
there's an important thing but you can
just barely get across the road now I
started to wonder if you could design
your time rather than just kind of
reacting to all of these defaults what
could happen so I started to sort of
this quest for a perfect week designing
a perfect week and in 2010 I started
running these experiments around Google
I called this a design sprint and I
because it sounded appealing to
engineers is fast and so the the idea
what the design sprint was you know I do
it with one team do it with another team
I did one with Gmail did one with Google
Ads with hangouts Chrome Google acts and
it started to sort of work better and
better tried to refine the process in
2012 I left Google and went to go work
at Google Ventures another alphabet
company and Google Ventures invests in
startups and so as someone who's you
know really like a dork about process I
was super excited to learn how startups
go from an idea to launch like what
happens when they go from you know
because they you think really fast turns
out pretty much the exact same thing as
everybody else now now this is not
exactly the way the mental model that
people have that startups to some of you
know I mean the idea is you get an idea
get it out there and get data on and
this is a really smart philosophy it's
kind of Lean Startup we're going to do a
quick loop and it's really smart because
then you don't commit to something
forever and get stuck with it as we did
but what happens is that most people
interpret this as we must launch an MVP
to get that data we need to build and
launch an MVP because then we'll have
perfect real-world data that we'll be
able to trust and the challenge comes in
building things it always takes longer
to build a high enough quality product
and so you end up with effectively the
same thing and at the end you tries tell
the marketing team to please explain it
so the idea with a sprint at a venture
capital firm when we were trying to have
our startups be as successful as
possible was to give them a shortcut a
way to get that data in just a week so
we tried to perfect that design of the
perfect week so that you could collect
data so fraggle for 150 sprints by this
point in my time at Google Ventures we
really kind of got to
what I want what I think is the perfect
week and I'm gonna just quickly kind of
tell you about it this morning so it all
starts with a challenge and hopefully
it's like similar to when you start your
new job and it's something you're
excited about something big but it could
be a new feature a new product whatever
and you assemble a team that's diverse
it's not just the product team just the
design team just the engineering team or
some special creative team it's the real
team with representatives from you know
marketing for instance and you take a
week of time on the calendar clear all
the meetings and then run a specific
script during that week and the idea is
to get rid of all those defaults and
reactions that we normally have and
instead follow a system so in some ways
it's like giving a high-five it's like
the system for the high-five is if you
watch the elbow you get better results a
little counterintuitive one of the key
defaults is that teams are often
fragmented we're in all those different
meetings we have different projects we
have different stand-ups and instead in
a sprint everybody gets together in the
same room so it it's happens the whole
week happens in one room together with
me with my eyes closed
no but do you all all together in the
same room in in the book sprint I've got
kind of a step-by-step guide for how to
run this process and it's actually it's
a checklist at the end of the book it's
literally 15 pages it tells you like
when to do this when to do that minute
by minute when you can go to the
bathroom it's very very specific but I
won't go through all the details now I
just want to tell you about what happens
on each day of the sprint there's kind
of one key focal point each day on
Monday the idea is to make a map of the
problem and in the common way that I've
experienced approaching products it's
it's hard to not think of everything all
at once all of the complexity of the
product and the Sprint we want a force
focus on one key moment so it's that
idea of trying to find the spot as we
did and didn't do at Encarta of the the
moment when the customer is picking up
the box or the moment when the customers
running a web search it's thinking
outside the product so here's an example
you can see a very simple map customers
on the Left how they move through in
this case some software for cancer care
clinics and in this case it's choosing
one customer
and one spot on that map where you're
gonna focus for the rest of the week on
Tuesday the whole team sketches
solutions for that challenge that
they've chosen and the default for
coming up with solutions as the team is
usually a group brainstorm
everybody's shouting out ideas but
working in this way really biases
towards people who are extroverted
people who can make a convincing sales
pitch for their idea people who other
people on the team think of as creative
and it does not allow for deep quiet
thinking it doesn't allow for you to put
a lot of detail behind your ideas often
an abstract idea will triumph in a
conference room when you're shouting
things out and it won't be as
high-quality over time so in a sprint
and work alone but we're together in the
same room is actually it's a little
weird I mean if you watch this video of
it happening it's everybody's kind of
quietly it looks like a you know test in
school but the idea is you have enough
time to think through how you think the
problem ought to be solved but you can
actually come up with a very high
quality solution and because people are
working on their own those solutions
stay separate this is what one of the
sketches might look like a lot of detail
behind it and by the end of the day
there's like 10 of them to choose from
10 different approaches so on Wednesday
you've got to decide which of those
approaches you're gonna go with and
which one you think has the best chance
of solving the problem often discussions
and these kinds of decisions can be
endless we can probably talk for an
unlimited amount of time to try to
decide which way our team should go
especially if we know we're gonna then
commit weeks or months or a public
launch or a lot of money to whatever
decision we make but in a sprint we make
those decisions fast and decisive by
making them structured and a bit
unnatural actually so we're following a
bunch of steps starting off by reviewing
things in silence so that nobody's
making a sales pitch for their idea
doing a structured critique that's very
fast it's not literally this fast but
it's quite fast everybody goes through
talks about the ideas and again with no
sales pitch from the Creator tries to
understand how they work and then
finally rather than have the team
collectively vote or have some kind of
an arguments about what's gonna happen
the decision maker one decision maker
makes the call about which idea will be
tested this is really helpful because it
sure as the product stays opinionated it
ensures that the product choice reflects
what the the decision-maker the leader
wants and it also makes that
decision-making process totally
transparent everybody can see how we got
there and on Thursday the team's going
to build a prototype so they've got only
eight hours and they want to make a
realistic prototype so that they can
then test it on Friday with target
customers and this sort of runs in the
same philosophy lafa coal vein as
building an MVP we want to build
something as quickly as possible so we
can get data the change in definition is
we're just gonna build something fake
that we can get reactions to and a
one-on-one conversation we're not gonna
worry about launching so the idea with
the sprint is you just faking things not
actually building a full product the
team splits up the work so they can
create as much surface area as possible
in the prototype and stitches it back
together
they're gonna use simple tools like you
might use keynote or PowerPoint to build
a prototype of you know a web app a
mobile app and iPad app and you can
quite quickly stitch together screens
that you've exported from a tool like
keynote into a tool like Flint Oh Marvel
or envision and stitch those together
with hotspots and make something that
appears in just a few hours to look like
a real app so here's is that same
prototype on a phone and you know looks
like a real app it's very convincing
when you show customers this they'll
react to it as though it were something
real there's a prototype of an iPad app
it appears to be in the App Store it
looks like they're installing it from
the app store but this app hasn't
launched yet those are faked screens
this is just keynote running fullscreen
on an iPad it appears to be real it's
possible to me prototypes of all kinds
of things I'll show you a few kind of
weird examples packaging so here's a
company who prototype the the way they
might deliver coffee in different sized
boxes with different brands each each
package there actually has a different
fake brand they've printed out stickers
to make it look real it's possible to in
many cases prototype something that's
extremely complicated like maybe a
hardware or in this case it's a software
that's actually for hedge funds to help
them predict company performance instead
of figuring out exactly how the
product should work they figured out
what the specs might be and what they
might charge for it and then they built
a very realistic sales deck tested that
instead service prototype so you can
also essentially create a play a theater
of your product and in this case this is
a company who it's a series of
healthcare clinics and they wanted to
experiment with opening their clinics
for pediatricians for families with
children are coming in they protect it
by setting up a stage effectively
putting props out things that they
thought they would need if they had
families coming in to the clinics and
they had a script they had actors you
know basically people from the clinic
from the office who would follow a
specific set of steps when people came
in the doctors would behave in a certain
way when they came back to examine the
patients and talk to the families and
all this is something they could plan
out in one day and then execute the next
day and he can even he can even
prototype snacks so one company actually
wanted to create a new kind of snack bar
it takes a long time to actually like
manufacture a snack bar in the way that
you know large scale so what they did
was bought a bunch of different snack
bars opened him up and painstakingly
like cut them apart and sort of glued
them back together with I don't know
honey or something and it sort of
created what might look like a snack bar
and then prototype the packaging and
wrapped those with very realistic high
quality packaging so Friday
you've got your prototype whatever it
might be it might be software might be
hardware device that you faked it might
be a snack bar of some kind and the
default that we usually have to follow
when we're building products is to wait
for perfect data and so even if we're
moving fast we're often thinking I've
got to watch in order to get that
perfect data but in a sprint you can get
quick and dirty data right away and we
do that with something that's really
usually very low status in most
organizations is it's usually something
we don't think of as being the way we
find out if we're on track for product
market fit just a one on one interview
just talking one on one to a customer
with no sales pitch showing them the
prototype asking them to think aloud
seeing if they can figure it out and
move through it this happens in one room
there's a video feed and then in the
next room is those five interviews take
place the rest of the team can watch and
take notes you can see it all happened
in real
and this is almost like you fast
forwarded into the future and you're
like peering through you know of a lens
at what might happen when your customers
encounter your finished product before
you've even started building it for real
so by the end of the day there's these
really clear patterns that emerge and
five people is actually enough to start
to see these patterns in a way that it
gives you a gut feeling that you could
trust about whether you're on track or
not in this case you've got five
different customers in each column and
the same thing shows up again and again
and again we know that's something you
need to pay attention to here's another
example often in the first sprint you'll
come across a lot of failures so here
again is five different customers each
column is a different customer everybody
except for the fifth guy who's having a
great Friday afternoon everybody else
hated the product and that's that's very
important for them to know but what
typically happens in a sprint is a team
will see the gaps between where they are
and what their customers are expecting
or understanding about the product and
they'll then be able to very quickly fix
it they starting to understand that gap
between their vision and where customers
are read sort of the real world is and
they can shift so this is quite common
again the same team the next week modify
their product ran another test and you
can see almost everything goes green so
the common way that I've heard of teams
applying the sprints into their regular
process is that at the beginning of a
quarter maybe when they do ok ours
they're setting aside a week and maybe a
couple days of the next week to run one
sprint fix the results of that Sprint
test it again and then they'll have
enough confidence to go all the way
through build and launch so I've run a
bunch of these sprints and I won't bore
you with telling you about all of them
but there is one that's pretty
interesting that I really like to tell
the story of so if you don't mind share
it this company is called savvy oak and
savvy oak makes a kind of an unusual
combination of hardware and service it's
a hotel delivery robot so I don't mean
it delivers hotels it works in a hotel
and it's it's actually about Bell a
little shorter than this lectern here
and the robot would be near the front
desk of the hotel so if I was working at
the front desk and it was
especially busy and I got a call
somebody calls and says they need a
toothbrush then I'm gonna be able to
open up this hatch on the top of the
robot put in a toothbrush
close the hatch again and type in you
know room 316 and then the robot which
is effectively like a little
self-driving car can then drive on its
own and just kind of like navigate going
around people and sort of get to the
elevator wirelessly call the elevator so
the elevator opens and it gets on and
it's writing people you know and then
the doors open on the third floor and it
knows it's the third floor so it gets
off and it's got this map and it knows
where the 316 is so it's gonna go down
the hall watch out for people and I get
there and then when he gets to the room
door it triggers a phone call so phone
rings in the room and sort of a robotic
voice says your delivery is here and
then and the person opens the door the
robot senses that and the hatch pops up
and deliver his babes and the robot goes
back you know he's just down the
elevator and back to the line
plugs itself in so it's it's kind of
cool I mean it's kind of cool stuff and
the the company who we had invested in
savvy oak they had figured out the
engineering part of this pretty well
they had made actually a prototype of a
robot that could do most of that stuff I
just described but they were at this
point where they had recognized they had
recognized an elbow effectively they
were wondering how the robot should
behave around people you know because
you don't encounter robots in hotels
every day that's people are not going to
be expecting it and these folks had
worked in robotics for a long time they
knew that there's a problem when people
encounter robots they have their
expectations are often too high we all
expect too much because we've seen too
much science fiction and we think that
robots have thoughts and plans and hopes
and dreams you know if this robot though
is not able to carry on a conversation
it can't follow a command they can't
answer a question it's not gonna be able
to talk back to you at all and they were
afraid that if they gave the robot any
kind of personality that it might
frustrate people people might be
disappointed they knew that when the
robot went out into hotels when they
finally launched that there would be
some attention people would write
stories about it people
right Yelp reviews about it and they
didn't want that storyline to be
negative they didn't want the thing the
message the message that people took
away to be to be negative because if
you're making something as capital
intensive as manufacturing a robot and
trying to service it and deliver it in
hotels if it doesn't go well if people
don't buy it right away as a startup
they would fail they would go out of
business so they had to get the launch
right and the safe thing to do was to
give it no personality at all just make
sure that it delivered on expectations
and many deliveries so they that was the
plan no personality at all but they
still kind of wondered and they had a
bunch of ideas for how they might make a
personality that that they thought could
potentially work could potentially be a
bit delightful for users but they they
just weren't sure and so they ran a
sprint to try it out so they did the
typical things on one day they made a
map that brought the whole team together
and again this is not just the
engineering team not just one part of
the team everybody's in the same room
the chief marketing officer for example
who knows everything about the
relationships with hotels and what
hotels are expecting and how hotels will
be talking about the robot to customers
they mapped out all of the places where
an unsuspecting guests might encounter
the robot you know by surprise not
knowing that there's gonna be a robot
making the delivery for example and in
fact that's the moment that Steve
Cousins the CEO savvy oak chose as the
elbow of the problem it's the key moment
when you get to your room and you get to
the door and you open it and there's a
robot there like that's Joe my god like
what's gonna happen that could be either
super awkward who knows what you're
wearing or it could be it could be
really great it could be really great if
it goes well because you're gonna have
an interaction with the robot as you get
your delivery so they decided to focus
there and for the rest of the week they
they worked on that on Tuesday they
sketched solutions and here's what that
looks like boring it looks boring looks
like you're taking a test but they came
up with a bunch of different approaches
and they sketched out some of their old
ideas that they had thought of before
that hadn't had the chance to really be
experimented with or thought through all
the way so on Wednesday they had to
decide from all those different
approaches
and Steve chose three ideas that he felt
were a little bit risky he thought they
could work and if they worked they'd be
great but they're not something we can
we can just go and ship with the first
idea was that the robot might be able to
play games with you you know so maybe if
you really enjoyed the delivery from the
robot maybe you could play like follow
the leader
with the robot or you know hide-and-seek
what the robot or something and the the
idea was that if that worked
and people were delighted by that kind
of play with the robot that it could
generate really positive reviews guests
would be super happy second idea was to
give the robot a face and this seems
really simple non-controversial but
actually if you don't want people to
talk to the robot a face is kind of the
thing that most says you can talk to me
they had some ideas they thought maybe
if they gave the robot a not too
intelligent face that that might be the
way to go but they weren't comfortable
launching with that they were not they
felt that was too big of a risk to
launch with so the try Atmos rent and
the third idea was to have the robot do
dance do dance after making the delivery
and I just go on the record to saying I
thought it's a really dumb idea that the
robot doesn't have any arms so what
you're dealing with here it's got some
wheels what you're dealing with is
something like this and this is how I
dance but I know I know from experience
it's not very effective at charming
other people so I was I was skeptical
anyway on Thursday they had to prototype
all of these personality traits on top
of their their early prototype robot in
just eight hours and so they divided up
the work and they've got one person here
you can see working on the sound effects
for the robot another a couple of folks
here are working on the face they're
actually just using keynote they're
making slides of the face putting hot
spots in some animations and putting all
that onto an iPad Mini so they pop to
the front panel of the robot off and
stuck the iPad Mini on and you can see
it here it looks like the robot has this
little sort of simple face and a little
speech bubble so that that implies I can
I can sort of put text in here but I
can't talk that was the idea they also
needed to figure out the dance moves and
normally the robots moving completely
its autonomous right it's just since
and running a program of script but they
didn't have time and they didn't need to
actually program all of that instead
Tesla had the CTO who you just saw she's
got basically a PlayStation video game
controller and the idea was that Tessa
would sort of hide around the corner you
know and just sort of like drive from
over here and make the deliveries do the
dance without people being able to see
so finally it's Friday it's time to run
the test and in order to make this as
realistic as possible they did it in the
hotel room and so early that morning my
colleague at the time Google Ventures
Michael he came to the hotel and this is
a picture of him in front of the hotel
and he came into the into the room got
out all his stuff and and and basically
set up like a like lights you know
taping wires to the wall and putting
dropped cams in the hallway and pretty
sure the hotel was cool with this and
and so there was cameras kind of all
over in the than we could see the the
company would be able to watch from
different angles how people reacted to
the hotel the unsuspecting like like
robot delivery so 9:00 a.m. the first
person shows up for the test and view
were just for a second put yourself in
the shoes of someone who well earlier in
the week you responded to an ad on
Craigslist and you saw there were these
for $100 there's like a usability
interview you're gonna be in Cupertino
that day anyway so you're like great
okay you fill out a little survey asking
you some questions you get an email back
from Michael and the email says hey this
is a little unusual but
in your life like ah this is you on
Wednesday you're like huh I don't know
$100 the hotel room not too sure what's
going on here but but if you're like me
you often commit to things in the future
that you know then when it comes you or
you regret so at that time you're like
oh yeah okay hundred dollars so but now
it's it's actually Friday you're
actually in the lobby Michael shows up
he's like come with me you're in the
elevator with Michael you're getting the
hotel room with Michael and there's
there's cameras everywhere so it sort of
illustrates though that actually talking
to your customers in this way it's
always uncomfortable it will hopefully
for you never be if I literally this
uncomfortable but but it will always be
uncomfortable to show people something
that's not finished it's not ready yet
it's not comfortable and most of us if
you're a designer you would probably
rather be designing things if you're a
writer you'd rather be writing things if
you're an engineer you'd rather be
writing code and if you're a p.m. I
don't know meetings or something I'm not
sure what you'd rather be doing but but
very few of us would would like to be
talking to a customer and not giving
them a sales pitch for why the product
is so good but actually just watching
them maybe trip over it asking them to
be honest and just talk about it this
isn't very comfortable so many teams
won't do it and if you do it you can get
data before they do now meanwhile while
this interview is going on Michael tells
this first participant he says hey I
want you to where would you if you had
just checked into this room where would
you put your suitcase and she says I put
it you know over here I guess on this
little suitcase stand okay so do you
unpack right away or later I might I
might unpack right away just you know
get stuff get stuff going what would you
do if you found you had forgotten your
toothbrush and she says I guess I'd call
the front desk and ask him if they could
send a toothbrush shop so Michael says
well once you go ahead and just do that
let's just see how that works this hotel
so so she calls the front desk
they say oh we'll send the toothbrush
right out so meanwhile we're watching
and the team gets to see what happens
from all these different it looks like
the Situation Room there's all these
different camera angles on the hotel
room and the hallway and we can watch as
the robot here moves into position so
it's moving into Tesla's driving it
right into position and then someone
from Savio calls the room back and says
your delivery is here kind of a robotic
voice and the person goes over and opens
the door and this is like this moment as
if we've peeked into the future and can
see what happens if the robot has a
personality how will people react and
respond to it and so it turns out that
after five interviews I can just I can
just give it all away to you it's five
interviews nobody wanted to play games
with the robot
in hindsight I guess it makes sense that
you wouldn't want to play hide and seek
in your hotel room with a robot
but it was one of those things that in
the abstract I could see why it might be
you know but didn't know the face
actually worked no one tried to talk to
the robot they thought it was cute but
they it was dumb enough looking I guess
and nobody tried to speak to it which
was great and the dance actually worked
the dance people liked to dance I'll
show you this is what the robot looks
like now that it's out and in real life
and service and you can see the dance
there's a simple face there and there's
a dance
I mean that is me but if it's so much
better when he does it so anyway this is
kind of a it's kind of a silly story
it's a little bit silly but when but
when they launched they actually as
predicted they did get a lot of press
coverage and here they are in the New
York Times and not the front page but
they are in the New York Times and the
story is quite a bit about the
personality that turned out to be a big
leader in how people saw and started
starting to adopt the robot inside a lot
of success in hotels kind of all around
the United States now and have a first
sale in Singapore doing really great but
the story here is really not about
robots because probably I'm sure less
than half of you make robots and your
company the story here is really about
the default the default is you have to
play it safe you have to be careful you
have to argue and argue and argue
because that launch is gonna be a big
deal we all know it's going to take a
while to get there even if it's an MVP
with a sprint you can take those big
risks early on and they're not really
that risky to you you're only wasting
week if you're wrong the default is to
focus on everything it wants to think
about how all the engineering and the
robot works to think about how all the
product
Encarta will work once you've got it
home on your computer but in a sprint
you can focus on that one key moment the
one spot that really matters most and it
might not even be inside the heart of
the engineering or the heart of the part
that we want to think about because it's
so challenging it might be somewhere
else it's effectively like like watching
the elbow it's not getting distracted by
the hand which seems like it would make
sense seems like we are we should put
our eyes but it's actually maybe
somewhere else and the Sprint gives us a
chance to change all the defaults
redesign the way we use our time and
focus where we really should
so if you'd like I encourage you to
either try a sprint if you want to try a
design sprint check it out but you can
also just think about how you might
redesign the way you use your time so
that your team and yourself aren't
always reacting to the defaults the way
the calendar happens to be set up the
fact that we expect each other to
respond to email right away all these
things have a cost and sometimes they
distract us from what matters the most
if you want to check out the book a
little bit of self-promotion here it is
take a look at it and if you really get
into it you can sign up for this
newsletter and send out stories about
companies who are doing sprints and and
events and things that are going on and
I'm also writing another book that's
about redesigning time and you will even
get news about the new book how exciting
is that thank you all so much for your
attention and I hope you have a great
[Applause]